good morning everyone thanks for rolling
in and adapting to all of your room
changes and all the rest as you can see
today we're continuing on in graphing
we'll be there until the end of this
week and right now we're moving forward
from if you remember last week we looked
at polynomial functions
we spent a lesson on absolute value
functions as well and we're going to
have a look at exponential and
logarithmic functions now I'm probably
sounding like a broken record but
there's kind of no more relevant time
than I can think of then now to
understand functions like this they're
very very relevant to the situations of
in going through our last few months
exponential and logarithmic functions
are all about functions that change in
proportion to their size change in
proportion to their size or maybe change
in proportion to their value is a better
way to say it so here are a couple of
examples of an exponential and a
logarithmic graph let's just briefly
look at them right this is a human
population growth chart over centuries
as you can see if you look closely at
the horizontal axis there and it makes
sense that you would have faster
population growth when you have a larger
population to grow from and that's why
you can see that number there or that
value of the function skyrocketing over
there on the right hand side of the
graph right so this is an exponential
graph we're pretty used to seeing things
like that and this is a logarithmic
curve or could be modeled with a
logarithmic curve over here on the right
whereas an exponential graph grows
faster the bigger it is what
characterizes a logarithmic graph or a
logarithmic function is that it grows
slower the bigger it is now this of
course is the situation we've been all
monitoring over the last few weeks and
months and the issue here is that well
why would these curves slow down it's
actually not to do with the virus itself
because that would be exponential growth
it's really because on the scale of
countries right the bigger the state of
the emergency is the more drastically we
act and so you know as the number of
cases and deaths goes up governments
around the world start to act more
dramatically and that's the whole
flattening the curve business right so
you can see as the numbers have
increased things have slowed
which is what you would hope would
happen if there was an appropriate
response and that's the characteristic
shape of a logarithmic curve the larger
the value is this slower that it grows
now it's worth mentioning that these are
both kind of human situations but we
find exponential and logarithmic
scenarios all around the world in the
natural world as well so here's just a
quick example for you and I promise I
will not turn this into a chemistry or
physics lesson but there's not just
exponential growth
there's also exponential decay and
people be pretty familiar I hope with
what you're looking at on the screen
this is how carbon-14 dating works right
carbon-14 as I think we're all familiar
with from like year 10 chemistry it's an
unstable isotope so over time it decays
into nitrogen-14 and here's the thing
right as the quantity of carbon-14
reduces well the amount of rate of
change also reduces because you've got
less carbon-14 to decay so the rate of
change is again proportional to the size
of whatever you're dealing with here and
instead of you know a population size in
this case it's a number of atoms that
are you know giving off radiation so all
of that just to say we see Exponential's
and logarithms all around us they are a
crucial piece of knowledge and skill to
master in understanding the world so as
promised we're looking at graphing right
now with exponential and logarithmic
graphs are mercifully they're actually
quite simple to draw which is nice you
saw some examples up above but there are
really four key features that we're
looking for I mean you should be trying
to aim for in terms of making sure you
have a good exponential graph or a
logarithmic graph we're going to draw
these graphs and then we're gonna
highlight the four features okay so
let's go ahead we'll start with the
exponential and what I love us all to
draw is let's go with black here let's
all draw y equals two to the power of X
so we're familiar of course with X when
you see it up there in the index that's
the giveaway that you've got an
exponential curve of some kind as
opposed to you know you don't have to
write this down but as opposed to a
polynomial where the X is in the base
okay so when you've got a that's to be
when you've got a curve like this you
could just put in some values right you
could say well what happens when X
equals zero that's an important value
I'll get to ^ 0 which is 1 what happens
when x equals 1 I'll get ^ 1 it's 2 and
it goes and it's skyrockets right so we
get this familiar kind of shape that
we've seen in those other graphs that we
were having a look at before and you
want to do it in one smooth motion so
that you have a good curve there if
you're not graphing in pencil please do
it because if you screw it up which is
fairly common then you can fix it up
fairly easily okay now you can see on
the screen the first feature that we're
looking for here right um the first
feature that really matters is shape so
this familiar exponential graph the
important thing is number one it's one
smooth curve and it gets steeper and
steeper forever and as you progress from
left to right as your X values increase
you get this steeper and steeper
gradient so you've got to make sure that
it doesn't you know topple over
you know and sort of decrease you don't
want it to become vertical and then like
back over on itself that's a bad idea so
you want to get that familiar
exponential shape happening okay there's
the first thing we're looking for the
second thing is actually something that
I signposted earlier the you can guess
because it starts with an eye it's this
one and only intercept that this
particular graph has now this is a
y-intercept so we let X equal 0 which is
what we did earlier and what you'll find
is of course your y-intercept is 1 so
that's the second feature you're always
going to have an intercept somewhere in
this case we don't actually have an
x-intercept and the reason for that is
because of the third feature it starts
with an A maybe you're shouting it out
to your teachers right now it is of
course the asymptotes now it's really
crucial especially now that we're paying
close attention to the graph that we
actually mark in where the asymptote is
this is an exponential graph so it has a
horizontal asymptote and um you need to
number one draw the asymptotes in and
number two actually tell us what the
equation of the asymptote is so you can
see it there nestled along the x axis
there that's why I'm actually not
touching there if you are trying to draw
your graph and your Cartesian plane with
the same color like you don't have red
and black like I do and then make sure
that your asymptote is is
clearly visible either in thick lines or
just slightly off of the axis so that we
can see it if you put it over the top
and in the same color and I can't see
your asymptotes then it might as well
not be there so make sure it's very
obvious and like I said before let's go
ahead and write down its equation y
equals zero okay so shape intercept
asymptotes most people are pretty good
at nailing down these three features but
there's one last feature that I wonder
if you can think back to when we having
looked at absolute value when we're
looking at polynomials every graph
actually needs these if they're relevant
at the moment this exponential graph
that we're looking at it might not be y
equals two to the X in its present form
it could be y equals 3 to the X or 8 to
the X or our hundred to the X what I
need is an additional piece of
information to sort of make sure it's
unambiguous that I know where this is
and maybe you're guessing now because
you can see it starts with RP what we
need is a point for scale or a locking
point as some people like to call it
now a point for scale this can go
anywhere on the graph so long as it's at
a convenient spot I like to choose an x
value that isn't hard to evaluate I've
already done X equals zero because
that's the y-intercept I'm gonna go with
x equals one now when I go ahead and
let's put it up here in the top right
hand corner to work it out I'm gonna
write PFS so that I can show what my
working is I'm gonna try x equals 1
which means y equals 2 to the power of 1
okay so therefore it's just equal to 2
so now I have a set of coordinates right
the coordinates are going to be 1 comma
2 now this is an important spot right to
pause you can't just now that you know
where it is you can't just put this
thing anywhere because the whole point
is that this thing see what I did there
whole point is that this has to be for
scale right so therefore like I just
like say oh I'm gonna make that my point
for scale it has to be in a specific
spot that matches the rest of the scale
that I've put here now let's not put
that point on my Y corner here is 2
right now I already have a vertical
scale in action because I've got this y
equals 1 spot here so if I'm saying this
is 1 then 2 had better be twice as high
above the x-axis otherwise I won't be to
scale like if I put the 2 value
up here then my whole graph is shot so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna position
it carefully I'll zoom in even if you've
got a rule or maybe you've got a grid
that makes it easier if if I've got my
one here then too looks like it's gonna
be better there do you go with that spot
that's twice as high right so therefore
let's go ahead let's mark that in so
when I go across to the right and see
where I collide with the graph this is
going to be my point for scale now it's
1 comma 2 and you can see it matches up
where my 2 is okay and you're done
those are the four features that we're
looking for shape intercept asymptotes
and a point for scale now even though
we're not going to look at logarithmic
graphs in more detail until the second
half of the lesson it makes sense to
actually really quickly have a look at
them now because the 4 features that we
just looked at shape intercept asymptote
and point for scale they're the same
four features that are relevant to this
graph because exponential graphs
logarithmic graphs they're kind of two
sides of the same coin
okay so we're going to go ahead and
we're going to draw this logarithmic
graph remember this is the overall shape
we're kind of going out here right
instead of getting steeper and steeper
forever we're going to get shallower and
shallower forever if that makes sense
ok so let's go ahead and again we'll try
and draw it in one smooth curve let's
give it a go whoops sorry guys okay so
there's my curve you can see it's kind
of going to very closely match the same
kind of shape you saw over there on the
exponential so shape ticked-off I've got
an intercept now because the lada
rhythmic curve is the opposite of the
exponential curve inverse is actually
the technical term then where we had a
y-intercept of 1 in this case you can
see I'm going to have an x intercept of
1 so you go ahead mark that in third
thing is the asymptotes now I previously
had a horizontal asymptote of y equals 0
so now you can see I'm gonna have a
vertical asymptote of x equals serious
so I'm gonna go ahead and I'm gonna mark
that in dotted lines and don't forget
the equation there
shape check intercept check asymptotes
lastly my point for scale I should have
mentioned by the way I even told you
what the equation of this logarithmic
graph is let's make it the exact
opposite the exact inverse of the
previous exponential we did
let's do log base 2 of X and the reason
why I do that
is purely because I'm lazy because I can
use that point for scale that I worked
out before if the previous point for
scale was 1 comma 2 then here this graph
is going to go through the the switch
around of the XS and the Y's it's going
to go through 2 comma 1 I'm gonna do the
same thing and I'm going to look at this
horizontal scale here if I've positioned
this as 1 then if I'm gonna go over to x
equals 2 it's gonna have to be rough
roughly double along otherwise my scale
will be inaccurate okay so that's the
spot I'm looking for its mark that in is
2 I go up to the curve and then here is
my coordinates and I'm gonna label it as
such
ok 2 comma 1